hi I'm Brianna from free code camp let's
quick review four basic parts of a
computer are the input like the mouse or
the keyboard the output what you're
seeing on the monitor or hearing through
the speaker's the CPU the central
processing unit and the memory now
memory can be short-term memory called
RAM or longer term memory that's usually
is a hard drive but can also be like a
cd-rom or flash drive anything like that
in addition to those four basic parts we
have three more things we're going to
discuss today the motherboard expansion
cards and power supply the motherboard
is what connects everything while the
data is flying around over here trying
to figure out where to go the
motherboard helps route it so it goes to
the right place expansion cards are
sound cards video cards that kind of
thing that can really up your experience
as a user power supply is as it sounds
what gets power to the computer it's
usually the part of the computer that
has that fan on it to keep it from
overeating so let's do a quick review in
addition to the four basic parts of
input/output central processing unit and
memory we usually have a motherboard
expansion cards and a power supply